Good morning, every new.
Good morning.
Hello.
I'm trying to fix my...
I'm trying to fix the window capture.
It looks so ugly.
Why is it...
Since when did...
Wait a second.
Since when did YouTube videos not...
Why is it not a perfect square?
Since when were the YouTube videos curved?
Maybe it's fun.
I'll get smaller once it starts.
Move your head.
It hasn't started yet.
Move my head once it starts.
Gosh.
It's been like that for a while.
Oh my god.
I didn't even notice.
Big head in the way.
What's it start?
I'll move my head once it starts.
Good morning, everybody.
Hello, I'm awake.
I'm a little sick.
I'm hoping for Tomodachi life, too.
That's all that I have to say.
I'm gonna turn on the sound.
Let's put on some music until it begins.
There might be, like, overlapping BGM, but that's okay.
That's okay.
What time is it?
Oh, we still have four minutes.
Let's put on a little bit so it's not just silence.
Because I'm just sitting here in silence.
I love this.
Mint dot your life tool.
Your head's not in the way.
It's huge though.
Stop making fun of my head.
It holds lots of secrets, okay?
I'm trying to set up.
I just got on my computer like just now okay i have i have
it open as you can see um i have the direct open you'll be
able to hear it and watch it so if you have it open yourself
um you can close it now i'm just kidding unless you want oh
um let me move it over a little bit too here we'll have it
like like a tv in the maid's cafe.
Hell yeah.
Oh, you know secrets?
Name all of them.
Secret one, secret two, secret three, secret four, secret
five, secret six.
I caught him in stream.
Yippee!
I forgot I remembered while you were offline one day.
Well, thank you.
Appreciate you sticking around.
I mean, you could...
I was going to say...
Please don't I remember.
Now that you remembered.
Now that you re-membered.
But like, you remember, but like you remembered.
Words are hard.
Oh gosh, I'm so tired.
I just woke up.
Like 10 minutes ago.
Wow.
What are you guys hoping for?
What is your hopes and your dreams, everybody?
I saw a lot of Silk Song.
Which, um, yep.
We're all on that hard copium, aren't we?
Who here just woke up?
Me!
Fire Emblem.
Tomodachi Life.
Zeno Blaine.
Silk Song.
Um, Tomodachi Life, ride or die, baby.
I mean, I'm already dead.
Ace Combat.
I think Mint is a member of the Lallie Lulelo!
No!
I hope they announced a game called Mint Phantom Super Meet
Super Mario.
I'm a tire.
That's me right now.
I have no expectations, I know nothing, I'm just here for a
good time.
Feature where your head is huge.
Can we not?
Welcome to the Silk Song Disappointment area.
Nintendo Direct.
How much time?
Oh, one minute left, everybody, one minute left.
only on the switch.
Yep, that's what they'll announce today.
100%.
I know.
It was leaked to me and my brand.
The aliens, they beamed it directly in.
First stream after finding you from Clips.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
I know you watch Vinny, but have you seen Joel watching
YouTube vids of some of your ghost cousins?
Joel.
Like, I don't think so.
I have not.
My ghost cousins.
Oh my god, that's my alarm.
Shut up, shut up.
When I think of Joel, I think of Joel, what's his name, Joel
Haver or whatever.
He always makes funny skits.
So I've watched his channel.
Oh, oh, oh, turn off the sound.
Oh my god it's kind of loud Yippee Let's go Nintendo Direct
baby
Oh Princess Peach Oh Luigi Oh Did he just speak?
No no no no no no no no no No no no no no no no no no No no
no no no no
Luigi game Wait is this Is this new Mario voice But it
doesn't sound so new Mario and Luigi Mario and Luigi Mario
and Luigi Oh my gosh look at them Spinning in tandem Wow
Look at him go!
Oh my god, so cute!
Connie!
Too cute.
Wait.
Okay.
I feel less, um, less self-conscious reacting because before
in the past, if I had to do a watch along, I had no audio.
It was just me talking.
And so now it's not just me in silence.
Wow, Peach!
You can't both be in love with Peach.
That's weird.
Connie's so cute.
Mario and Luigi.
Brothership!
Hello, everyone.
I'm Shinita Takahashi.
your guide for today's Nintendo Direct.
That was the first new entry in the Mario and Luigi series
in almost nine years.
No way!
Mario and Luigi's brothership.
Maybe they should have resought today.
Please look forward to a seafaring adventure that unfolds
across mysterious islands, as well as evolved bros moves
with Mario and Luigi.
Bros moves!
Okay, let's see the first batch of our lives.
funny is on the side like under the recommended for me five
years ago silk song announcement trailer the thrill of the
nintendo world championships is heading to the nintendo
switch system oh the thrill over 150 speed running
challenges from across 13 nes games from lightning fast
beats to action-packed battles poppin wheelies familiarize
yourself with each challenge and Best shot and aim for the
top of the online leaderboards.
Oh no.
You can also try more difficult legend challenges.
It'll be an imposter.
Like completing Super Mario Brothers in one go using warp
pipes.
Stuck on a legend challenge?
Check out classified information for handy tips and tricks
to help you improve.
It looks like retro.
Like even the guide.
Where you'll race against ghost data of players worldwide.
Whoa!
will be eliminated you've only got one shot to survive will
you be the last one standing Nintendo World Championships
NES edition launches on Nintendo switch literally
speedrunning game pre-orders for the digital version are
available now on Nintendo eShop a deluxe set containing a
physical version of the game okay love Mario and Luigi
series I can't believe it Wow oh my gosh the collector set
Oh my god, Viya kugumiya!
We live the climactic Alvarez Empire arc from the hit anime
fairy tale in this action RPG.
Said in the vast kingdom of Fiore, Team Natsu prepares to
finish their fight.
This is...
I was gonna say, this isn't a warriors type game, is it?
Koi Tatsu?
They use different kinds of magic based on who's in your
party.
Fairy Tale 2.
Work together with your teammates to take down...
Oh, I like her.
I don't remember her name, though.
The red-haired girl.
Uh, E.
It starts with an E, right?
Fairy Tale 2 launches on Nintendo Switch this winter.
Fairy Tale 2!
Anime!
Embark on a multi-dimensional journey.
Did Icarus Uprising Remaster?
Let's go.
Nobu Sakaguchi and composer Nobuo Uematsu.
So Final Fantasy.
Final Fantasy.
Final Fantasian.
The world is slowly being robbed of its civilization.
Whoa.
To restore his memories, Leo must confront an evil entity.
There's eggs everywhere.
Vincent?
Skills are the ticket to winning battles.
Near Fantasy.
Yeah, it looks like near.
I thought Nero first too.
Come on, Nero.
You can also send enemies you've encountered to a separate
Dimension and fight them later.
Is that how you spell Dimension?
Dimension.
It's not a Dimension, it's a Dimension.
Not the Dimension though.
Let them go.
Now, let us save the world together.
Fantasia, Neo Dimension.
Launches on Nintendo Switch this holiday.
The dementia dungeon.
Another sport is coming to Spoko Square.
Wow!
I still haven't played this though.
Basketball is being added as a pre-up date to the Nintendo
Switch sports game.
Dribble?
Sorry.
And shoot.
She's watching the lady like so casually dribbling.
So funny.
Three point challenge solo and score as many baskets as you
can.
Yeah, shoot lady, keep going.
Woo, you're killing it.
Four players can also compete in five streak battle.
Oh no, I can feel myself raging from that already.
You can team up with players worldwide in two-on-two online
matches.
She shoots.
She scores.
Switch, baby.
Dunks its way on Nintendo Switch this summer.
Alright.
We ballin'.
We ballin' Minto!
It could never be ballin' like this.
Shut the heck up.
I was in basketball before.
Whoa.
What is this?
But it looks kind of like...
The music is nice.
I like it.
It's one ugly looking thing.
I think it's kind of cute!
It's like...
It's got some nice hair.
Mio!
Memories and orbit.
What?
That's it?
We're just not gonna address that.
We're just gonna...
Everybody, we didn't even watch that.
That was a fever dream.
Dio's Mr. Manaw.
Uncover hints and evidence scattered throughout the world.
Disney game.
Then use the dashboard to crack each case.
What?
What big secret lies at the end?
Start sleuthing because this free update launches on
Nintendo Switch later today.
Okay.
Cool.
Hello kitty!
Where's my baby?
Where is he?
I'm scanning everywhere.
Customize your character.
Oh my god, stop.
So cute.
I love not Animal Crossing.
Let's go!
Ah, there he is!
Son of a rat!
Where is he?
Hello Kitty Island Adventure launches as a timed console
exclusive Oh my god!
Why are they?
Look how tiny he is!
Oh god, he's so small!
Let's get Looney in this wacky sports game.
What?
Bug's Bunny, Daffy Duck, Porky Pig, and more.
Across four arcade-style sports.
Whoa, we are balling today.
What is going on?
But watch out for falling ant bills.
Looney Tunes' wacky world sports.
What is a space jam?
But it's not space jam.
That's all, folks.
Let's see if you can be a game on.
Why does he sound like he's stuck in a...
Oh, no.
New crewmate and imposter roles are being added to Among Us.
Excuse me, where's my royalties?
Or turn invisible while taking out players?
What?
Suss things out when this free update for Among Us...
Today!
Wait, but it's only for the Switch?
It's only for the Switch?
This is Felicidad.
Felicidad!
Those who command and raise them are called Farmagia.
and play a vital role it looks is this the artist for fairy
tale 10 a farmagia must rise up against the oppressive magus
among us with somebody raise monsters and lead them into the
fight against the magus oh my god it's marvelous plant seeds
then cultivate and harvest them to make your buddies come to
life i'm growing dogs what's going on be trained for battle
fairy tale 3 let's go Oh my god, look at this whole army!
It's like Pikmin-esque.
Oh my god!
By these guys, let's go.
To call forth a giant fusion summon and wreak havoc on your
foes.
The horse is just standing still.
What is going on?
In Pharmagia.
Launching on Nintendo Switch November 1st.
Farmagio.
Okay.
Cool.
Donkey Kong!
Donkey Kong Country Returns, originally released on the Wii
System is barreling onto Nintendo Switch in HD.
The villainous Tiki Tiki!
Tiki Tiki!
The local wildlife and stolen Donkey Kong's precious banana
horde.
Oh!
Yeah!
Punch him in the face!
And roll on through.
Each level is filled with hijinks.
But they're no match for these top bananas.
From manic mine carts.
It looks good.
Oh.
To high-flying rocket barrels.
And even hitching a ride on Rambi.
There are plenty of transportation methods available.
It's kind of like triggering me, though, that they weren't
taking out all the...
Oh my gosh, it looks so cool!
They weren't taking out all the spikes, you know?
They weren't clearing it out.
I should have cleaned it up.
The original version had some awful motion controls.
I mean, that's just the Wii, right?
Monkey?
Monkey!
One of Donkey Kong and Diddy Kong's jungle escapades returns
in HD.
Plenty of wild actions and antics are in store with these
Kongs.
Look at this little Nintendo hat.
Please take a look at this.
Jungle.
The time is nigh.
I thought it was Zelda for a second.
Tokyo Metropolitan Symphony orchestra.
Wow, thank you for your service.
Dragon...
Wait, it's actually Dragon Quest?
Bum-bum.
That's why I wouldn't know.
Journey with allies to face the Archfiend.
Wow.
An epic adventure.
Dragon Quest makes me so sad now, though.
Memorable encounters.
It looks good, though.
It looks really good
Wow an iconic RPG remade in HD 2d HD 2d is such a funny It
looks so like the sprites look so fluent Go share the
picture with the 50k
Aw the legacy begin What's a good Dragon Quest to start?
Dragon Quest III, HD 2D remake.
Coming to Nintendo Switch, November 14th.
None of them.
11.
8, 11.
I saw someone say 3.
Oh?
Oh my god, they totally bait and switched us.
It's all three of them!
Nintendo Direct, hello everyone.
It's cute.
It's so cute.
So cute.
So I'm so happy to see you.
Surprise!
Dragon Quest 1 and 2 HD 2D HD 2D is really hard to say in
Japanese, I think.
EU Stream, good morning!
Good morning!
3, 1 and 2 in that order.
Interesting.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Thank you, Mr. Hori.
Three, one, and two in that order is what he said.
Herdric Trilogy.
Now in HD2D.
Let's continue with more headlines.
Vivi Kour, thanks for the five gifting.
Like Metal Gear.
Let's have some fun, Ko.
No.
Say hello to.
Jaws?
No.
He-Man?
Great Scott.
Is that Marty McFly?
What is going on?
The world of Funko is coming to light in this
action-adventure mashup for the ages.
Oh my god.
This is a game to rival Fortnite.
You should explore locations based on over 20 iconic movies,
TV shows, and more.
Use special skills and crafted gadgets to explore epic
worlds, each with their own unique puzzles, hidden areas,
and familiar foes.
Oh my god, no.
Oh my god, is that Chucky?
Oh my god, oh my god.
My co-fusion pops on to Nintendo Switch September 13th.
We've got a smorgasbord of Spooky.
I love Spooky.
And strategic games.
Okay, Spooky?
Spooky.
Oh.
It's Luigi.
Summon your courage.
Hello?
And explore multiple mansions.
filled with goofy ghosts goofy ghosts excuse me I don't like
this game I'm feeling targeted right now that's a Luigi's
Mansion 2 HD that's a Luigi today you pervert Luigi why
would you scream you're the one meet the quirky little Dempa
man Dempa man what explore dungeons and battle monsters.
Dempaman!
Decorate your island however you'd like and more.
Plus, up to four players in local co-op can team up to catch
special Dempaman.
The new Dempaman is free to play and launches as a timed
exclusive on Nintendo Switch July 22nd.
Okay.
I'm setting my July.
Dang, it's June.
Strategize away in this tower defense installment of the
Metal What?
Take control of your forces.
Oh no, tower defense.
Oh no, oh no, tower defense.
Tower defense with anime movies.
Tactical tussles.
Metal slug tower defense.
You can also slug it out with other players in online
battles.
Metal slug attack reloaded.
Storms onto the Nintendo Switch system later today.
Oh no.
Uh oh.
an expedition of the dam in this eagerly awaited sequel to
the darkest dungeon too board your stagecoach and set off i
never played darkest dungeon though to prevent an apocalypse
fight off nightmarish fiends in turn-based combat and
upgrade your abilities after each deadly run matara coded
game extremely hello hello solidus again later today on
Nintendo eShop.
More classic titles are on the way.
This expansion pack.
Play Link's classic 16-bit adventure and team up online to
explore randomized dungeons in the Legend of Zelda.
I've never played Four Swords, though.
I didn't have anyone to play it with.
Experience the remake of Samus' first adventure in Metroid
Zero Mission.
yeah coming to the new Nintendo 64 Nintendo switch online
mature 17 plus collection of games mature brave the
dangerous lost land we were just talking about this game we
no way and
oh infiltrate a corporation to end their alien conspiracy in
perfect dark now with online multiplayer i feel so targeted
right now all four games will be available for nintendo
switch online let's go i've been wanting to play perfect
dark though for a while so set sail to save the day this guy
this is marona a young woman with the ability to communicate
with phantoms
I will take care of this girl.
In this new installment in the Phantom Brave series.
They're so cute.
Take on tactical turn-based battles.
So Disguaya team, or Disguaya artist?
Maggie!
So cute.
Combine phantoms with certain objects to maneuver them.
It's cute, but kind of slow.
I could never get into Diskaya because of that or anything.
I'm just not a huge fan of turn-based stuff.
Which, like, it seems like it's totally mine.
Oh, my God.
Stop, they're so cute.
Oh, oh, so cute.
Lots of phantom stuff today, too.
This is my direct.
this one's gonna take you for a ride oh no are we doing what
street seven arcade games featuring marvel and capcom
characters are fighting their way onto nintendo switch as
one collection wow that's a lot of games xmen versus street
fighter duke it out marvel versus capcom 2 new age of heroes
take down the king the beat them upside scroller the
punisher and more The Punisher.
Hit up training mode to polish your fighting skills and
combos.
Oh, wow.
Select online mode to challenge rivals around the world.
Oh, no.
Captain America is getting his eyes wiped.
You can also cross over to the museum to view artwork.
Ooh, that's cool.
I love stuff like that.
Oh, thank you.
Capcom Fighting Collection, Arcade Classics.
Launches on Nintendo Switch this year.
Hold on, I'm going to grab some tissues.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
The latest game in the Mario Party series takes place on an
enormous island resort.
Uh-oh.
Get ready to jump into the biggest selection of Mario Party
mini-games yet in.
Oh, no.
A Super Mario Party Jamberry!
First, let's see some of the new boards where you'll compete
to collect the most Oh no!
God no!
Coconut Mall!
Rainbow Galleria.
Use in-game coins to get a star at half price when they're
on flash sale.
Oh my god.
Could other people stay on track in Rollum Raceway.
Who was that guy that took the star?
You can move up to 40 spaces with a lucky roll.
Here on Goomba Lagoon.
Goomba Lagoon!
And things really get mixed up when the volcano blows its
top.
Oh, just kidding Along with five new game boards two boards
from previous Mario Party games make their return No, God
no.
Oh, oh look at all the booze and the chain jump so cute And
more oh God battle of wits controlled by gently shaking or
tilting your joycon controllers.
Okay With over 110 mini games there's a wide variety to
enjoy oh god also how there's a lot of people oh 20 people
this is too chaotic no way compete against your rivals and
aim for first place 20 people your best there's too many are
you kidding me right now wait there are even more new modes
the biggest Mario party yet will soon be underway when the
Super Mario Jamboree game launches on the Nintendo Switch
system October 17th perfect streamer version oh no that was
the latest installment in the Mario Party at that point it's
just fall guys with new boards mini games 20 player online
get ready for the biggest Mario online though I wonder if I
could do it on like stream that'd be fun but the Those games
are probably too long, right?
Like for it to be with viewers.
Zelda?
New Zelda?
Wait.
Not new Zelda, but...
If it's a new 2D Zelda though...
Wha!
Oh my god!
He's like, I'll kill you next time!
Wait, actual Zelda game?
Actual Zelda game?
What's going on?
Wait, actual Zelda game?
No way.
Zelda Zelda game?
This is the year of the ladies.
everybody first we get peach and now we get Zelda Zelda
they're gonna call it link producer of the legend of Zelda
series I love the little like dead link on his shirt the
latest installment the legend of Zelda echoes of wisdom this
time around I love 2d Zelda this is count as 2d Zelda it's
like a little 3d you might be thinking will Zelda fight with
a sword then tell the real here we wanted to create a new
gameplay style that breaks conventions seen in past legend
of Zelda games with a top-down perspective okay to explain
more please take a look at this video HD 2d yes I'm very
curious stolen away across the vast lands of Hyrule.
Strange rifts have appeared.
And have taken many people.
By Link.
Now alone, Zelda meets the fairy Try.
Retrieves a mysterious staff called the Try Rod.
Just try harder.
Just try harder, Zelda.
Try Rod at a table she found.
Zelda learned how to create an imitation of it called an
Echo.
Okay.
learn an echo of something you can recreate it whenever
you'd like oh neat there's a wall blocking your path you can
create echoes of tables to get a leg up just like that oh
cool you can create wooden boxes old beds i can make a box
in a bed how you use them separately or together oh my god
it's a minecraft water tower learn and create echoes of
things you find while Whoa.
Oh my god.
There's so many combinations you can do.
What?
That's kind of cool.
Even battles will look different.
You could pick up and throw a rock echo, for example.
Oh, damn.
That's not all, though.
You could also create echoes of monsters.
Oh my god, there was like a little tiny version of them.
After doing so, they'll fight by your side.
What?
Monsters have different abilities.
But what does it cost?
right based on the situation wisdom is key what does it cost
to like summon something whoa interesting I think it would
still take me it would it would take me a minute to get used
to this oh my god how was that How was that?
I hope you enjoyed this demonstration of the Echo.
That looks so fun though.
Which channels Princess Zelda's wisdom.
The great Echo Tree.
There are a lot of Echoes in this game.
They even have the little spiky guys!
How you solve puzzles and battle enemies will change
depending on the Echoes used.
In short, we've created a game where each player's
experience will be different.
Yeah, everybody can, you can play as you want.
The Legend of Zelda Echoes of Wisdom launches September
26th.
That's so fun.
light system inspired by the Legend of Zelda series will
also be available at launch oh it's pretty isn't this just
the necromancer monkey now I'd like to return this moment
I'd stolen away back to mr.
Takahashi thank you mr.
Aonuma how could you say that you stole it away you're mr.
Aonuma Sama you're so legendary
More headlines, is that what he said?
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Sorry, I have to turn off the audio for this.
I don't want to get copyright struck.
It's K-pop, I think.
That looks like Lady Gaga.
Hot new tracks.
Oh.
Ariana Grande.
See ya.
Green day.
Oh, yeah, there's Lady Gaga.
Oh, cool.
I've never played, actually, one of these games before.
But I've, have you guys, did you guys know that these are,
like, real people that they just put in this makeup and
then, like, put a filter on top?
Like, there's people, the people that are dancing actually,
like, look like, They have like a bunch of face makeup and
stuff on.
Oh, okay.
We're good
Legos on the horizon It's the world I'm very curious about
the green day go for dances Join machine hunter a loy on a
quest to save the world from an ancient evil Oh journey
through life landscapes.
Okay dive deep into the cauldrons Climb up on the tall necks
and traverse other locations inspired by the original game.
What be careful?
swarms of machines are lurking everywhere use an array of
gadgets like blast boots and gravity bombs to hunt them down
I never played the what it was the game watch to mighty
sawtooth horizon what was it called come across the fearsome
thunder jaw oh just horizon as you progress you can help
Aloy rebuild oh my god cute and customize her appearance
with lots of hot dog oh and you don't have to explore this
vast wilderness alone.
Team up with familiar faces from the world of Horizons in
two-player local or online co-op.
Okay.
Lego Horizon Adventures launches on Nintendo Switch this
holiday.
No, I saw a hot dog.
I saw it for real.
Stray!
This is another game I wanted to play, but didn't have a
chance to.
Oh my god, little baby.
Oh no!
Don't just stand... Oh my god, Simba!
I'm gonna score!
Keep moving fast!
It's a decaying cyber city through the eyes of a cat,
separated from their family and friends.
Explore alongside a drone known as B12 to find your way
home.
Wait, was this not on the switch before?
Carefully climb to the highest heights.
Live the king.
And stealthily squeeze into tight spaces.
Think like a cat to make your way through the city.
It was only PS4?
Oh, okay.
Careful though.
Not everyone is excited to have you slinking around.
I'm just a cat!
Inclusive host of hostile creatures ready to swarm.
Keep exploring to venture into more areas of this unfamiliar
world.
Oh, and PC.
Oh, okay, okay.
And make your way back to safety.
Stray finds its way onto Nintendo Switch this holiday.
Oh, okay.
Neat.
Welcome home, Hobbit.
That's rude.
If you've ever wanted to live like a Hobbit, I know I'm
short, but come on.
Now, a leisurely existence nestled away in an idyllic, quiet
corner of Middle Earth can be yours.
Customize your appearance, decorate your home, and settle
into life in the Shire.
style you'll be friend your neighbors work together to solve
problems and even share a meal I love how anytime it's like
customize your house it's just like animal crossing the best
way to build a hobbit community is by hosting a dinner party
with your homemade dishes Wow I can poison everybody for
unique decorations or special ingredients for even tastier
meals friendly hobbits and familiar faces await your arrival
when the hills of the Shire A Lord of the Rings TM game.
A Lord of the Rings TM game.
A Lord...
What?
No!
Two Ace Attorney spin-off games, including a sequel that was
previously unreleased by Shadow Japan.
No way!
One collection.
As the prolific prosecutor, Mario Zephyr, take the prince
out of the courtroom and investigate crime scenes.
Oh my god!
Check for information by interviewing people and inspecting
evidence.
Let's go!
We can say it!
We're scared!
Yeah!
Finally!
Or swap to the original character visuals from your original
series character designer or swap to the original sprites
for a more classic movie.
Oh, fun!
Oh my god, I love when they do that.
Yeah!
Let's go!
I will find character art, music, including orchestral
arrangements, and more.
Past and present collide as you uncover.
Yippee!
Ace Attorney Investigations Collection launches on Nintendo
Switch September 6th!
So far for now!
Yippee!
Oh no, Danganronpa?
It's a normal day.
Uh-oh.
I was like yay anime oh no Danganronpa I don't think it is
or is it I don't think it is though I think it's just the
same art style
after a devastating attack by unknown assailants Oh no
Takumi Samino's life gets turned upside down a mysterious
school mascot suddenly appears.
Me?
You?
I hate when I'm forced to go to school.
Oh, who's the girl behind him?
With the tongue out!
Who is her?
My neurons have been peaked.
Oh, there she is!
Ah!
Dadumi.
Oh, yo.
Kumi survived this 100-day trial.
This is his brain.
Maybe that is not me.
Or you.
The creators of Danganronpa present.
Danganronpa.
The what?
Oh wait, I can't read it.
What is that?
What does that say?
I can't read the font.
I didn't hear what he said.
Oh, the 100 line.
A full remake of Romancing Saga 2 is marching on to an end.
Nintendo Switch.
Oh!
I'm sure there will be people excited about this.
An empire of Barren across multiple generations while
challenging the legendary seven heroes who have turned to
darkness.
Oh no!
Someone mentioned the door to darkness?
In combat, use Return of Saga features.
Yeah, a lot of remakes, yeah.
And formations to enhance abilities.
Turn-based battles have also evolved.
into timeline battles, where the action order is key.
Oh.
Innovative features like United Attack can also help with
strategy.
What is up with these brainy creatures?
And in which order will you fight the seven heroes?
Every decision you make will dramatically alter the course
of the story.
Why didn't you pick that, you coward?
Serves her right.
seven heroes may emerge victorious.
Heartbeat.
Romancing Saga 2, Revenge of the Seven, launches on Nintendo
Switch October 24th.
Ha ha.
We hope you're excited to experience the full remake of
Romancing Saga 2.
Oh my gosh, it's already almost been an hour.
That's almost everything for today's Nintendo Direct.
Uh oh.
The next will be our last announcement.
Tomodachi... Uh-oh.
The last announcement, you guys!
I'm holding my breath!
No!
Wait, it could still be Tomodachi Life!
It's a Metroid.
Samus!
Tomodachi Life!
Come on, Bane!
Switch us!
Ooh.
FPS, Samus?
Interesting.
Space pirate.
Whoa.
Nasty.
Let's go.
One more trust.
2025.
Okay, next year guys.
No silk song.
No Tomo Tachi life too.
That was a first look at Metroid Prime 4 beyond.
After a very long time, we are finally able to share more
information about this title.
Releases planned for 2025.
So please wait a little bit longer.
That's what he's telling everybody to silk sock.
Please wait a little bit longer.
That's all for today's Nintendo Direct.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you.
Ace Attorney!
That's all I'm thinking about right now.
That and the...
That and the new Zelda game.
Thank you for hosting this watch-along.
Thank you guys.
Thanks for joining.
Thanks for hanging out.
Sorry no Tomodachi Life, Minto.
It's okay.
The, the, the, you know, when they stop, or rather, when
they keep not announcing it, the more watch-alongs will do.
The more watch-alongs will do since I'm just, I'm holding
out, maybe?
We didn't get sconged, but we got new Zelda.
New Zelda looks interesting.
Though, I'm not sure how I feel.
I actually really like how you fight in Zelda and stuff, so
not having my little sword and everything makes me a little
sad, but we'll see.
Still looks interesting.
Mario Brotherhood.
Call it what it is.
It was Brothership!
Don't erase the brother ship!
That's where the gumshoe can be your to-modachi, stop!
Yeah, we have the try- what was it?
The try-hard, the try-wan, the try-fairy.
Hmm.
That was fun, though.
Hold on.
erase that was there anything else oh it just says thank you
for watching and it's over i'm looking at some like the
thingies the what's it called they gave me
the recommendations and right there silk song announcement
trailer five years ago oh man I stand for the brothership
Can't believe mint doom stream manifested to rock I know
right That too We were literally just talking about it
That's so funny Love watching these with you Thank you Ruby
Oh yeah And the metal slug tower defense It said it was
gonna be available today right I will be I will be grabbing
it I will be downloading that I love tower defense
That's a, it's, I've wanted to play, isn't it Arcanite's
also tower defense, but I've heard it's really hard, so Silk
Song died, so the brother-brothership could sail.
I got news, Ace Combat 7, not in the direct.
But release on the Switch, July 11th.
Wait, really?
Was that in the Japanese?
Wait, what was in the Japanese direct that we missed?
Um...
Japanese Nintendo Direct.
Uh...
Maybe I should have watched the Japanese one.
Metal Slug T.D.
is actually a mobile game that's getting ported.
Oh!
Really?
Oh, Nyerhodo.
Nyerhodo.
Um...
uh direct maybe I should go to hold on I wonder if she has a
link I see Korone stream up so I'm just gonna I wonder if
she has oh she does have a link yippee thank you Korone
I'm scrolling through the What did they start with?
They started with...
Oh, Mega Man!
Hold on.
Let me, uh...
Let me get the window up.
Window capture.
Yo.
Sorry, the cut's gonna be a little ugly, but...
Or the crop, rather.
There we go.
Let's see what we have, what we missed in the giant...
Japanese one.
Mega Man, Mega Man.
Oh, sorry.
Rock Man.
Was the Japanese stream longer?
I don't think so.
Can make it a little bit bigger.
There we go.
We're not going to watch the whole thing.
I'm just going to skip through it.
Rock Man World 3.
Oh my god, my eyes.
I didn't know they had different things.
I'm skipping.
Is this the brother ship?
No.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, wait.
Stop, please.
Wait.
No, it was Paper Mario RPG.
What is this?
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
Okay, hold on.
I saw something else though.
Oh, this fish game.
What the hell is this?
Fish.
Wait, this is how it hasn't even started.
When does it...
Oh, maybe it has...
Oh, here's the actual direct.
I'm just going through advertisements at the moment.
Oh my gosh, I'm an idiot.
Sorry, guys.
I'm going through...
I just read the bottom.
It says it starts at 11 is what it says.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's my alarm.
Sorry.
Whoopsie.
There we go
I'm looking at the fish man.
I was excited about the fish.
Okay, we got the brother ship.
We got this same thing.
Oh the Lego horizons.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That Fantasian games, sports.
What is this?
Oh.
Metal Slug.
Oh, not Fairy Tale 3.
What is this?
There's always like one of those fashion games, you know?
Oh, Mickey Mouse.
I also...
It's also so curious what, like, the order's so different,
too, you know?
Dragon Quest.
The Capcom.
What is this?
But there is a fairy tale 3.
Look at the little wheeze.
Moro KT, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
A monkey ball.
No, but a bird.
Not the monkey ball at all.
Yeah, I want to Sugoshi.
What is this?
Wow,
hot.
What is this?
Oh, perfect dark.
Just kidding.
The mashing.
I'm skipping forward.
Fairytale.
actual fairy tale
Phantom Of course there's power pro It wouldn't be The j-
Did you see him?
Metal Gear Mansion Let's go
It's snake Oh my god he's even in the three Pose Let's go
That's my little Hi!
That's my little
bake!
Okay, we'll be released once we get the Delta.
Oh, it just popped open.
Is he still in an egg?
Yeah!
It's the same little guy!
Like, I knew that they were gonna be in the...
Well, actually, well, I didn't know that they were gonna be
in the game.
Wait, so does that mean, like, Pyramid Head and Goemon
and...
Yippee!
I'm so happy just to see him right there!
Skim!
Oh, it's so wet.
It's really...
Ooh, it's so wet.
Oh my god, Silk Song!
They announced Silk Song for the JP side, everybody.
I'm...
What is this?
Oh!
There's so much going on here!
Don't give us hope!
Ninja Slayer!
Renatus?
Oh, here's a Mario party.
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Legend of Zelda, skip, skip, skip.
Skip, skip, skip.
Stray, skip, skip, skip.
Oh, Dempa Men's.
Skip, skip.
What is this?
Fall guys?
They're so round.
What?
What is this?
The true silk song is the friends we made on the road.
So true, Sebastian.
Enki party!
I love that name!
I'm so excited.
No.
Look how cute!
Oh,
that looks so good.
Oh, Francisco!
Oh my god, what have they done to her?
Oh, the art looks so good.
Oh, God.
Oh, One Piece!
See, I feel like this could totally be announced for us too,
right?
Anime.
The one piece is real.
They totally glossed over it.
They were like, by the way, there's one piece.
Just the deluxe edition of the game RPG.
Fair... no, not that...
Oh, the slime!
I almost said fairy tale again.
It's the slime!
Wow!
Oh, Gundam!
Boom!
Fairy tale floor!
Oh, rhythm game.
Looks a little slow though.
Umamushame!
No!
When will we get our umamushame?
Oh, Natsumon!
I am...
Okay, but not Danganronpa.
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Skip, skip, skip, skip, skip.
Wait, oh, sorry.
Skip too far.
I got too excited.
What's this?
Looks pretty ominous.
Wait, no, this is just the...
This is the saga, isn't it?
This is the saga game, is it not?
Romancing saga?
Yeah, yeah, my bad.
And then...
Metroid.
And that's it.
Really?
Maybe there's some other stuff that I, like, accidentally
skipped over, but...
Not too much of a difference.
Luigi?
Uh...
Brothership.
Yeah, like they start...
Oh wait, no, this is the...
Okay, there's because...
Not too much of a different.
It's just a little bit.
They didn't even have one of those like fashion games.
I'm so shocked.
Where is JP Funko?
Yeah!
They didn't do the Funko...
A Funko Pop game!
Woohoo!
I can't believe we're getting Funko Pop game.
Well, guys, that was a direct.
Oh, my God.
No, there was some...
There was some...
A lot of...
A lot of remakes, right?
JP doesn't get Fasbear Funko game rip.
Rip, indeed.
That was fun.
Yeah, that was fun.
Maybe you skipped Tomodachi Life, too.
Yeah, of course.
I can't believe the Funko Pop game is actually like it feels
like it's rivaling Fortnite in terms of like you know
Everybody like there's so many different collabs.
You could see so and so fight so and so I remember once the
JP direct announced a new Super Robot Wars game Big hype
moment for me.
Thanks for the watch along.
Thank you Yeah a lot of ghosts in this direct a lot of
phantom mentions And of course...
What was this?
I skipped over it on accident earlier.
That looks a little spooky though.
I'll never forget the one time I was hoping for new Fatal
Frame.
And they did the direct while I was at work.
So I was like...
Oh, it's right after Sanrio crossing.
Very text-heavy horror game.
That part is terrifying.
And they look so happy about it.
They're like, woohoo, we're almost gonna die.
For some reason, the stream just does not want to.
Look how tiny he is.
My little dog.
He's so cute.
He's the king number one, baby.
I can't believe Pom Pom Pudy.
got booted i think it's been like a decade since pom-pom
pudding has not been in the top three and pom-pom pudding
got top four he was fourth in this year's sanrio ranking
it's kind of crazy pochaco is number two i believe karomi
was three um pom-pom pudding was four Filo Kitty was five, I
think.
Why is it loading?
Okay, 53.
Oh,
he's so cute.
He's so cute even when he's making witchcraft.
Love it.
Thanks for the stream and going back to work.
Good luck with work.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god, it's not Higurashi.
So this is a series.
Never heard of it before though.
Whoa!
Oh, I said Higurashi.
Maybe I should have said Umineko.
Oh my goodness, the amount of text.
It's so cool, though.
They know the honey.
I want to play!
But my Japanese is not Jozu.
Oh well.
Umineko mentioned, let's go.
I mean, they're on an island.
If someone's dying, you know, mucho text, though.
Cool.
ever played famicom detective club not yet not yet sadly
this probably won't get translated the first two have it
unless there's like a fan translation but yeah probably
probably not probably not play game become jozu the thing
about those types of games is that since they're made for
like uh they're made for like you know an audience like a
mature audience so i'm just like
Oh no.
Can't read.
I would have to like, I would get very Josu probably.
But this is how, but this is a long time ago.
I feel like a lot of people learn from visual novels and
stuff.
I learned from Love Plus.
I learned a lot of stuff from Love Plus.
So, and then I forgot it all.
But yeah.
So, yeah, a lot of people learn from visual novels, I feel
like.
Love Plus mentioned, a game will probably never, ever get
again.
So sad.
Thanks for the pink!
Thanks for taking this watch along.
Any games you're interested in streaming?
In streaming?
I don't know about that.
Maybe the Metroid game, but I would want to play the other
ones too, right?
Ronan, thank you!
Eternal Kamioshi.
Thank you so much.
But, um, the love plus gotcha died.
Love plus everything died.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, ducky.
My wife gets released and some friends and I will be pulling
for her.
May you bestow upon us your blessing on our firefly.
You would firefly, man.
Ooh, mint neko.
It's okay if you just bless mine, I won't tell.
I bless you and your Firefly poles.
Moe, moe.
Pole.
Please.
I like Firefly.
I think she's very cute.
Though I don't know anything about Honkai.
Can you curse them instead?
Coming from a ghost, it might be a curse instead of a
blessing, right?
Would you recommend Love Plus for Japanese learning?
I think so.
I think I would.
Because it's always better to learn from something that's a
little bit more conversational, right?
Fun fact, when Umineko was releasing, it would take months
for Ian to get a translated version of their software that
would read the screen and translate the game.
Some of the oldest memes have come from that.
three games that way.
Oh my gosh, Saku.
Your bread.
Well, guys, this is fun.
Thanks again for joining me.
For watching the watchalong, the direct together.
Nanda, this.
I guess, you know, Blade X remake will have to wait for
Switch 2.
Yeah, where's our Switch 2 announcement, huh?
Face Combat 7 and already an announcement.
on switch during january ah i see i see the producer phrase
combat franchise confirmed the release date today on twitter
ah got it got it nice i wonder how it'll play on the switch
though no wonder see you tonight for more outer wilds yes i
will be streaming again tonight outer wilds so um short
stream today but uh for for now short stream for now and i
might see some of you some more outer wilds and if not then
I'll see you maybe what am I playing tomorrow playing deal
or no deal tomorrow yippee I just wanted to play deal or no
deal for some reason I don't even know how to play that game
but um yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a minto and um yeah I'm
gonna go maybe take a nap have fun with the metal slug game
thank you yeah maybe i'll stream that maybe i don't know
what to stream from maybe donkey kong um yeah
yeah ace attorney i should return to ace attorney
I'm gonna go eat some breakfast too.
I'm hungry Otsuminto, everybody.
Thanks for joining.
Thanks for hanging out.
Thanks for watching I hope there's some things that you guys
are excited for and if not, there's always next direct
What's up, Minto guys?
See you guys maybe see some of you later and if not, um, see
you when I see you Otsuminto, it's up, it's up.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye,
bye-bye.
Bye.